bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir à tous bonsoir à toutes
et à tous les autres aussi bien sûr
bienvenue donc à cette 47ème cérémonie
bien décidés à fêter le cinéma et dont
l'humeur oscillera entre la mi temps du
superbowl et une soirée karaoké avec
michel houel bec entre titane et tisanes
mais que c'est bon de voir une salle
pleine une sale venue célébrer le cinéma
français qui cette année grâce à ces
réalisatrice à remporter la palme d'or à
cannes julia ducournau
le lion d'or à venise audrey diwan
et je sai qui doit supporter en échange
les plaisanteries parfois discutables de
cet inoxydable maître de cérémonie qui
est au rendez vous une fois de plus pour
la dixième édition la dernière fois que
j'ai présenté les césars benjamin
voisins étaient encore qu'une hypothèse
dans la tête de ses parents et jacques
audiard portait encore sa coupe afro
mais assez parlé du passé ce fut une
belle année pour le cinéma malgré les
contraintes avec des films qui ont
réussi à toucher tous les publics du
cinéphile le plus exigeant au cinéphage
le moins regardant des succès bac nord
backdoor c'est bien
mais mais mais si gilles lellouche avait
mieux travailler il aurait pu rester en
filière générale l'a toujours
merveilleuse valérie lemercier valérie
où es tu
elle est ma vie elle est maligne 1 et 2
aussi nous aussi on à malines
ok catherine corsini est sorti des
urgences
est un tueur arts arrive de la jungle
temps onoda
arthur avarie
merci pour lui
dauda arthur harari nous raconte
l'histoire d'un homme qui ne sait pas
que la guerre a pris fin tandis que ce
soir nous faisons comme si la guerre
n'avait pas commencé et pourtant et
pourtant comment ne pas évoquer ce qui
se passe en ce moment même à 3h10 y est
bien déjà en disant que ce que nous
célébrons aux césars et précieux l'art
la parole libre le travail d'équipé
alors évidemment ce soir on ne va pas
changer le monde on serait mal placé
pour donner des leçons c'est fait beau
on va rire on va être ému par ce que
l'essence de notre métier c'est de
continuer quoi qu'il arrive même si le
monde semble s'effondrer autour de nous
ce soir nous pensons aux ukrainiens et
soyons à la hauteur de la chance qu'ils
n'ont pas s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]